I brought up um if anybody I'm just
putting this out there to the table this
decision by the Biden Administration to
stop all pro um permits for liquefied
natural gas that is actually clean or
burning and that our allies need in
order to prevent them from dealing
getting their energy from China and
Russia it doesn't make any sense you
know I refer to it Dana as a
schizophrenic approach but I mean that's
been that's a benign way to describe it
it really is an approach that is
political so you're able to say to the
Americans I'm doing this or I'm
supporting Israel or we're attacking
them or you know we're we hit them 65
times or 85 whatever the number was but
at the same time saying to Iran look
we're going to let you have that 10
billion doll waiver and the $6 billion
do for the hostages and we're going to
let you sell oil on the international
market and that's what's so frustrating
to me I don't want to have a war any
more than anyone else but I think re is
Right we've got Americans all over the
place all over in Iraq and Syria and I
understand but you know we that we need
to keep an eye on ala and everybody else
but when Donald Trump was president and
I don't want to make this political but
you had a leader who said the Iran
revolutionary guard corpse I'm going to
kill their leader solaman took him out
that was it and then Joe Biden he leaves
Afghanistan how many billions of dollars
worth of armaments are in the Middle
East and I believe they're using them
against us now so you the administration
is not stupid there is some other agenda
going on where it's not just yeah we
have to do this but we got to let China
do this we got to let Iran do that and
we don't want to fight them and we got
to give them warning and we want them to
know we don't want to have a war hey you
kill an American you should have an A a
war you know judge you and and both the
general General Kellogg brought up the
instance with Donald Trump making a
threat to the Taliban and then striking
suani and that backing off of Power what
I would offer up is this this Donald
Trump is an exception to the rule Donald
Trump is one of the reasons he was so
hated by both the with the machine that
exists within Washington DC that is now
gearing up for yet another War whether
not it was left or right Republican or
Democrat there was enmity towards Donald
Trump and I think it's in part because
it stood in the way of moments like this
when you need some sobriety to say if
I'm connecting the dots correctly we
have presence scattered around this area
for counterterrorism those targets then
get hit then we now to I'm just
listening to the conversation throughout
this first 35 minutes Greg then we have
to go hit the people that hit us and we
live under this delusion that's just
going to stop them one big stop and
they're not going to of course that's
set against the backdrop of about 50
years of talk of regime change in Iran
and we have a great history of regime
change that's worked out really well in
Afghanistan of course now we're regime
change in Afghanistan and it feeds in
stability and Chaos across the greater
Middle East everywhere we go in to set
stability and before you know it we've
seated the ground for more terrorism
that comes back and hits us which
undercuts the original purpose of
putting troops in the place in the
Middle East in the first place as
counterterrorism I just think we might
need some sobriety before we fire up the
war machine on this cycle that seems to
always end up in American death and why
why was it that there was so much going
on with al- Qaeda and all the beheadings
and the bombings and then in six weeks
you get rid of the caliphate when Trump
came in he gave the generals full
Authority go in there and get rid of it
he got rid of them but but to to Will's
point and I think you you're speaking to
something that's absolutely right
because I think you have to rewind the
tape before you get to Donald Trump
right because you're absolutely right
when we talk about putting the when you
talk about the calip when you talk about
Al-Qaeda when you talk about Afghanistan
you talk about the death of our troops
and you talk about how our troops died
and I think that's the the hardest part
about it is they died with weapons that
we sold to the people to begin with in
the 80s them or or sitting in the desert
but but I mean let's go back to the
1980s when we were literally selling
weapons to many of these places that use
those weapons to then kill American
American troops I the history of this
region and this is not the only region
where this is the case anytime America
goes into places and says we're going to
build a democracy here right or we're
going to make this place better and
we're going to sell weapons to this
place and give them a chance what ends
up happening is Americans end up dying
as a result it might not happen in that
decade might not H it might happen two
or three decades later but it's the
weapons that we sold them the decade
before hey we did a great job with
regime change in Ukraine that worked out
really well I I I'm sorry I'm like I'm
sitting at home watching the five right
now and I'm just going
like don't Don't lecture me on
deterrence we don't have any deterrence
anywhere especially in the United States
we have no idea what an incentive or a
disincentive is I obviously I've become
very cynical about this I mean I spoke
out about Ukraine the the first week it
started it's called a Putin puppet and
now we're two years into it we' got what
70,000 80,000 Ukrainian dead and that
all could have been prevented but you
know we had have a war you
know anyway I have no you know I'm no
expert on this but I know if I were
sitting at home right now I feel like
all of this information and all of this
speculation you heard it before you're
going to hear it again we're just
filling a bucket hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else